Joe: We weighed iconic
fast-food-menu items
in the US and the UK and
compared their prices
to see which country is
getting the most for its money.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, a small cheese
pizza will cost you £11.99,
which is around $15.54.
That's a price per square
inch of 21.8 cents.
Small in the US?
$9.49, which is about 12
cents per square inch.
I know I got a small,
but apparently they're also doing
small peppers with the small pizzas.
Look how small this is.
Skimping on the peppers, eh, Papa?
An XXL cheese pizza in the UK
will cost you around $23.32,
which is a price of 12.3
cents per square inch.
USA's extra large? $15.49.
That cannot be right.
Sprinkle a little math on that,
that's 7.7 cents per square
inch. That is so cheap.
So, what can we take away from this?
Well, in both countries,
the more pizza you buy,
the cheaper it gets.
In the US, the price per
square inch of a small
is 55% more than an extra large.
And in the UK, it shoots
up to a huge 77% more.
I mean, it makes sense, right?
I mean, that's how they get you.
They pretty much are tricking
you into getting more pizza
'cause it's cheaper per
square inch, so you're going,
"Oh, I'll just get the
extra large instead."
And then a year later, you're fat.
"Whoops! It was such a good deal!"
Harry: In the UK, that's
$1.95 per 100 grams.
In the US, that's $2.36 per 100 grams.
That makes them 21% more
expensive in the US.
And we're going to weigh the Big Mac
and see if there is
any difference in size.
I'm not sure there will
be, but let's find out.
Find out how much a large
fries weighs in the UK.
That's a cost of $1.94
per 100 grams in the UK.
That makes them 14% cheaper in the US.
Next up for the US is our large,
which is a 14-inch diameter.
Harry: 100 square inches of
pizza in the UK would cost $15.
100 square inches of pizza
in the US would cost $9.70.
That makes it 35.3% cheaper in the US.
We want to make sure that
you're getting the same amount
of filling as you do in
the US here in the UK.
So what we've got here is
a foot-long Italian BMT
on hearty Italian with lettuce and olives.
We're going to weigh it
to see if the quantities
are the same. All right.
BMT.
We're going to weigh the large fries
to see the comparison between UK and US.
That makes them 15% more
expensive in the US.
Per 100 grams, the US
Whopper is 6% cheaper.
This is a crunchy beef
Taco Supreme in the UK.
The UK price is $5.18 per 100 grams.
That makes it 49% cheaper in the US.
This is a UK chicken quesadilla.
That's 27% cheaper in America.
This is a Crunchwrap Supreme in the UK.
This has an estimated weight,
and it should weigh 146 grams
if the website's ingredients
information is correct.
But ours actually weighs 154 grams.
So we're actually getting
more than expected.
We're about a hair over 150. OK.
We're going to weigh the
cup and then also the extras
to see if what you get really is a bonus
or if it actually all adds
up to the supposed total.
165.
So, first, we'll do the scale, right?
So this is supposed to be 411 grams.
Let's see what we got.
What is this? 170?
Woof, guys, that's not even close.
So, our regular cup of fries
actually only contained 165 grams,
which is less than half of
what you're supposed to get.
We're going to weigh the rest of the fries
to see if that makes up the difference.
So, even with all the bag fries,
which we assigned to the regular portion,
we're still only looking at 276 grams,
which is well below the portion size
you're supposed to be
getting for a regular.
Excellent idea, Harry. I will do the same.
Now we are up to ... 275?
Still not even — it's supposed to be 411?
So it looks like we've been a
bit shortchanged on the fries.
Because it was all given
to us in one big bag,
it's hard to tell which
portion came out small.
So what we're going to do is
add the little fries to this one,
get a total figure for all three portions,
and then figure out how much
we've been shortchanged overall.
So, we've done the maths,
and between our large,
regular, and little fries,
including the bag fries,
we only got 830 grams.
However, we were supposed
to get 1,220 grams,
which means we've been shortchanged
by roughly a third here.
Joe: With the rest of the bag fries,
the large, and the little.
So they gave us 851 grams of fries
total.
They're supposed to give us 1,225.
Hey, Siri,
851 is what percentage
of 1,225?
Siri: About 69.4693%.
69%.
Nice.
So, at least in our case, it seems as if
the generosity of Five Guys
has been a bit overstated.
Maybe they just overfill
smaller containers,
so you kind of think you're
getting more than you should be,
whereas in reality, if you measure it all,
you're actually maybe getting less.
So, we're going to weigh
this burrito half at a time
to see what the total is.
In the UK, we can only get
one size of guac on the side.
It's supposed to be 4 ounces.
We're going to measure it
to check if that's the case.
That's a price of $3.58
per 100 grams in the UK.
The US version is therefore 26% cheaper.
So, which country gets
more pizza for its money?
In the UK, a large cheese pizza
will cost you £15.99.
That's a price of 15
cents per square inch.
The US large hand-tossed
cheese pizza is about $13.99,
which is about 9 cents per square inch,
making it about 40% cheaper
than the same pizza in the UK.
We're going to weigh
the double ShackBurger
to find out if it's actually
the same size in the UK
as it is in the US.
Joe: Oh, man. Ours weighs a lot less.
Significantly less.
What's up with that, Shake Shack?
In the UK, we can only
get fries in one size.
And this is it.
In the US, we also have
only one size of fries.
Let's see how much theh blegh!
What I meant to say was,
let's see how much they weigh!
Harry: So, our portion of
fries came to around 188 grams.
What? Did he say 188?
Ours is, like, a little over 100.
Like, when I say 105, I might be generous.
It's a lot less.
Harry: 100 grams of doughnuts in the UK,
it's costing you $5.96.
That makes the American
doughnut 56% cheaper.
Now, it might not make too much sense
to compare just one Munchkin
in the UK and the US,
because I'm sure they're all
slightly different shapes
and sizes. However, what we could do
is measure 24 Munchkins
here and 24 Munchkins there
and hope that it provides
a kind of overview
of the average weight.
This right here is a standard
USA Krispy Kreme classic glazed doughnut.
I want to bite into you so bad!
But before that, let's weigh it.
Harry: Per 100 grams of
glazed doughnut in the UK,
you're paying $4.39.
That makes the American
doughnuts 6% more expensive.
We're going to weigh 10
plain wings in the UK
and do the same in the US
to see how they match up.
So, 10 plain wings in
the UK came to 290 grams,
which is an average of 29 grams per wing.
Joe: Ugh, way higher, dude.
360 grams.
I needed my calculator app
to determine what 360 divided by 10 is,
and it is, in fact, 36 grams.
Wow!
So our average is 36 grams
per wing here in the US.
So five plain tenders in
the UK weighs 230 grams.
Joe: 200 and what? Way
over 300 on this one.
Bigger chunks of meat over here in the US.
Bigger tender chunks of meat.
[Harry laughing]
That's not a good look for fries.
How do I get this back in?
Laura: Just like that!
Harry: And the large
portion came to 255 grams.
Joe: Our regular is bigger
than your large, UK.
Dips in the UK only come in
one size, and it's regular.
We're going to weigh a cup of
ranch to see how much we get.
Now the big boy.
I couldn't even guess how
much this container weighs.
Conner: What's your best guess?
Before I do this?
Conner: Yeah.
Closer to 300. This is heavy.
This is, like, a half a bottle of ranch.
Bro!
It is 440.
440 grams of ranch.
[crunching]
Hm. OK. OK.